namaskar
i'm a movie star i'm 51 years of age
and i don't use botox as yet son
i'm clean but i do behave like you saw
like a 21 year old in my movies
yeah i do that i i sell dreams and i
peddle love to millions of people back
home in india
who assume that i'm the best lover in
the world
if you don't tell anyone i'm going to
tell you i'm not but i never let that
assumption go away
i've also been made to understand there
are lots of you here who haven't seen my
work
and i feel really sad for you
that that doesn't take away from the
fact that i'm completely self-obsessed
as a movie star should be
and that's when my my friends uh chris
and juliet called me here
to speak about the future you naturally
it follows i'm going to speak about the
present me
[Applause]
because i truly believe that humanity is
a lot like me
it is it is it's a it's an aging movie
star
you know grappling with all the newness
around itself wondering
whether it got it right in the first
place and still trying to find a way
to keep on shining regardless i was born
in a refugee colony in the capital city
of india new delhi
and my father was a freedom fighter my
mother was well
just a fighter like mothers are
and much much like the original homo
sapiens
we struggled to survive when i was in my
early twenties
i lost both my parents which i must
admit seems a bit careless of me now
i do remember the night my father died
and i remember the the driver
of a neighbor who was driving us to the
hospital
he mumbled something about that people
don't tip so well and walk away into the
duck
and i was only 14 then and uh i put my
father's dead body in the back seat of
the car
and my mother besides me i started
driving back from the hospital to the
house
and in the middle of a quiet crying my
mother looked at me and she said
son when did you learn to drive
and i thought about it and realized and
i said to my mom
just now mom
so from that night onwards much akin to
humanity in its adolescence
i learned the crude tools of survival
and and the framework of life was very
very simple then to be honest you know i
thought
uh you know you just ate what you got
and did whatever you were told to do
i thought uh celiac was a vegetable
and uh vegan of course was uh mr spock's
lost comrade in star trek
you married the first girl that you
dated
and you were a techie if you could fix
the carburetor in your car
i really thought that gay was a
sophisticated english word for happy
and lesbian of course was the capital of
portugal as you all know
so we relied on systems
created through the toil and sacrifice
of generations before
to protect us and we felt that
governments actually worked for our
betterment
science were simple and logical apple
was still then
just a fruit owned by eve first and then
newton
not by steve jobs till then i'm
impressed and eureka is what you
screamed when you wanted to
run naked on the streets you took where
you went wherever life took you
for work and people were mostly
welcoming of you
migration was a term then still reserved
for siberian cranes not human beings
uh most importantly you were who you
were and you said
what you thought then in my late 20s i
shifted to the sprawling metropolis of
mumbai
and my framework like the newly
industrialized aspirational humanity
began to alter in the urban rush for a
new more embellished survival
things started to look a little
different i met people who had descended
from all over the world faces races
genders money lenders definitions became
more and more fluid
work began to define you at that time in
an overwhelmingly
equalizing manner and all the systems
started to feel
less reliable to me almost too thick to
hold on
to the diversity of mankind and the
human need to progress and grow
ideas were flowing with more freedom and
speed
and i experienced the miracle of human
innovation and cooperation
and my own creativity when supported by
the resourcefulness
of this collective endeavor catapulted
me into superstardom
i started to feel that i had a right and
generally by the time i was 40 i was
really really flying
i was all over the place you know i'd
done 50 films by then
and 200 songs and i'd been knighted by
the malaysians
i'd been given the highest level honor
by the french government
the title of which for the life of me i
can't pronounce even till now
so i'm sorry france and thank you france
for doing that
but much but much bigger than that i got
to meet angelina julia
for two and a half seconds and i'm sure
she also remembers that encounter
somewhere okay maybe not
and i i sat next to hannah montana on a
round in a table
with a bag towards me most of the time
like i said i was flying from miley to
jolie
and humanity was and humanity was
soaring with me
we were both pretty much flying off the
handle actually
and then you all know what happened the
internet happened
i was in my late 40s and i started
tweeting like a canary in a bird cage
and assuming that you know people who
will peer into my world will admire it
for the miracle i believed it to be but
something else awaited me and humanity
you know we had expected an expansion of
ideas
and dreams with the enhanced
connectivity of the world
we had not bargained for the
the village-like enclosure of thought
of judgment of definition that flowed
from the same place
that freedom and revolution was taking
place in
everything i said took a new meaning
everything i did
good bad ugly was there for the world to
comment upon and
judge as a matter of fact everything i
didn't say or do also
met with the same fate four years ago
my lovely wife gauri and me decided to
have a third child it was claimed on the
neck
that he was the love child of a first
child
who was 15 years old apparently he had
sown his wild oats with a girl
while driving her car in romania
and yeah there was a fake video to go
with it and he was so disturbed as a
family my son who's 19 now
even now when you say hello to him he
just turns around and says but bro i
didn't even have a european driving
license
yeah in in this new world
uh slowly reality became virtual and
virtual became real
and i started to feel that i could not
be who i wanted to be or say
what i actually thought and humanity at
this time
completely identified with me i think
both of us
were going through a mid-life crisis and
humanity like me was becoming
an overexposed prima donna i started to
sell everything
from hair oil to diesel generators
humanity was buying everything
from crude oil to nuclear reactors you
know i
i even tried to get into a skin tight
superhero suit
to reinvent myself i must admit i failed
miserably and just an aside i want to
say on behalf of all the batman
spiderman and supermen of the world
you have to come in commend them because
it really hurts in the crotch that
superhero suit
yeah i'm being honest i need to tell you
this yeah
really and and accidentally i happened
to even invent a new dance form
which i didn't realize and it became a
rage so if it's all right and you've
seen a bit of me so i'm quite shameless
i'll show you it was called the lungi
dance
so if it's all right with you i'll just
show you i'm i'm talented otherwise yeah
that's right it went something like this
lungi dance lungi dance
it really did
like you noticed nobody could make any
sense of what was happening except me
and i didn't give a damn really because
the whole world
and whole humanity seemed as confused
and lost as i was
i didn't give up then i even tried to
reconstruct my identity on the social
media like everyone else does
i thought if i put on philosophical
tweets out there people will think i'm
with it
but some of the responses i got for the
streets were
extremely confusing acronyms which i
didn't understand you know rofl
lol adidas adidas somebody wrote back to
one of my more thought-provoking tweets
and i was wondering why would you name a
sneaker i mean why would you write back
the name of a sp
sneaker to me and i asked my 16 year old
daughter and she enlightened me
adidas now means all day i dream about
sex
is it really i don't know if you know
that and so i wrote back
wtf in bold to mr adidas
thinking secretly that some acronyms and
things
won't change at all wtf
but here we are i'm 51 years old like i
told you and
mind numbing acronyms notwithstanding i
just want to tell you
if there has been a momentous time for
humanity to exist
it is now because the present you is
brave
the present you is hopeful the present
you is innovative and resourceful
and of course the present you was
annoyingly indefinable
and in this spell-binding imperfect
moment of existence
feeling a little brave just before i
came here i decided to take a good hard
look at my face
and i realized that i'm beginning to
look more and more
like the wack statue of me at madame
tussads
yeah and in that moment of realization i
asked
the most central and pertinent question
to humanity and me
do i need to fix my face
really i'm i'm an actor like i told you
a modern expression of human creativity
the land i come from is the source of
inexplicable but very simple
spirituality
in its immense generosity india decided
somehow that i the muslim son
of a broke freedom fighter who
accidentally ventured into the
business of selling dreams should become
its king of romance
the bacha of bollywood
the greatest lover the country has ever
seen
with this phrase yeah yeah which which
has alternately been described as ugly
unconventional and strangely
not chocolatey enough
just the people of this ancient ran
embraced me in their limitless love and
i've learned from these people
that neither power nor poverty
can make your life more magical or less
torturous
i've learned from the people of my
country that the dignity of a life
a human being a culture a religion a
country
actually resides in this ability
for grace and compassion i've learned
that whatever moves you whatever urges
you to create
to build whatever keeps you from failing
whatever
helps you survive is perhaps the oldest
and the simplest emotion known to
mankind and that is
love a mystic poet from my land famously
wrote
which loosely translates into that
whatever yeah if you know hindi please
which loosely translates into actually
saying that all the books of knowledge
that you might read and then go ahead
and impart your knowledge through
innovation through creativity
through technology but mankind will
never be
the wiser about its future unless it is
coupled
with a sense of love and compassion for
their fellow beings
the two and a half alphabets which form
the word prem
which means love if you are able to
understand that
and practice it that itself is enough
to enlighten mankind so i truly believe
the future you
has to be you that loves otherwise it
will cease to flourish
it it uh it will perish in its own
self-absorption
so you may use your power to build walls
and keep people outside or you may use
it
to break barriers and welcome them in
you may use your faith to make people
afraid
and terrify them into submission or you
can use it to give courage to people
so they rise to the greatest heights of
enlightenment
you can use your energy to build nuclear
bombs and spread the darkness
of destruction or you can use it to
spread the joy of light
to millions you may fill the up your
oceans callously and
cut down all the forests you can destroy
their
ecology or tend to them with love
and regenerate life from their waters
and trees
you may land on mars and build armed
seatables
or you may look for life forms and
species to learn from
and respect and you can use all the
monies that we all have earned
to wage futile wars and give guns in the
hands of little children
to kill each other with or you can use
it
to make more food to fill their stomachs
with
my country has taught me the capacity
for a human being
to love is akin to godliness it shines
forth in the world
and shines forth in a world which
civilization
i think already has tampered too much
with
in the last few days the talks here the
wonderful people coming and showing the
talent
talking about individual achievements
the innovation the technology the
sciences the knowledge we are gaining
by being here in the presence of ted
talks and all of you
are reasons enough for us to celebrate
the future us but within that
celebration
the quest to cultivate our capacity for
love and compassion
has to exert itself has to assert itself
just as equally so i believe
the future you is an infinite you
it's called a chakra in india like a
circle
it ends where it begins from to complete
itself
a you that perceives time and space
differently
understands both
your your unimaginable
and fantastic importance and your
complete
unimportance in the largest context in
the larger context of the universe
a youth that returns back to the
original innocence of humanity which
loves
from the purity of heart which sees
from the eyes of truth which dreams
with the untampered which which dreams
from the clarity of an untampered mind
the future you has to be like an aging
movie star
who has been made to believe that there
is a possibility
of a world which is completely wholly
self-obsessively in love with itself
a world really it has to be a you
to create a world which is its own best
lover that i believe ladies and
gentlemen
should be the future you thank you very
much
[Music]
thank you
[Music]